well good morning everybody good morning
morning for those who've joined us on
youtube
uh and good morning to all members of
the committing officers
to the meeting of our plans committee of
the 1st of october
cranky we are kneeling to winter now
before we start i've just a few things i
want to read out
that we do every at every start of every
meeting
um at the start of the meeting
we will mute all microphones except mine
and please leave all microphones muted
unless you're asked to
buy me to speak residents who want to
exercise this right have been asked to
register
in advance and have also had the option
of sending the statement to us
which will be read out by an officer or
have been
sent a link to temporarily join the
meeting to speak in person
and we've got uh one two six
people down to speak today who've
applied to speak
to indicate to me that you would like to
speak or
propose a second emotion please press
the raise the hand symbol
in the participants menu on your screen
these are shown on my screen
in the order that they are pressed and i
will deal with them
in that order giving the appropriate
officer or counselor
the opportunity to answer in between
when necessary
i will also return to the counsellor to
check that they're happy with the
response
to ensure clarity and accuracy during
virtual meetings
all votes will be cast via a verbal
recorded
vote and names will be read out by the
clerk in alphabetical order please state
your vote
clearly and slowly when your name's read
out
unmuting and muting your microphone as
necessary
please remember that to ensure full
transparency this democratic process
of this meeting is being live streamed
on the council's youtube channel
which of course i mentioned at the start
i ask you all to be patient during the
meeting
and to understand that the processes and
advice may take longer than usual
i will now ask each member of the
committee and then the officers to
introduce themselves
so the clerk will read out names in
alphabetical order please
sandra thank you chair
cancer bowtoen yeah good morning richard
bowden i represent heartland
councillor brown
good morning i represent great
torrington
councillor christie good morning
uh i represent biddeford north
pennsylvania
good morning councillor chris leather
and i'm representing northern
councillor locke good morning get out of
the log i
watson pete watson i represent
broad heath and councillor wiseman
morning i represent the shebia and
langtry ward
and thank you thank you thank you
sandra and with this is pleased
introduce themselves please uh good
morning members
of the public my name is sean harrington
i'm the development manager at charles
district council
good morning my name is damian hunter
i'm the solicitor i'm helping out
from northampton district council today
thank you
welcome damian thanks very much
good morning everyone my name is james
jackson i'm the development management
team leader at torres district council
thank you
is that it is that the end of the office
tracy you're their principal planning
sorry good morning my name is tracy
blackmore i'm
a principal planning officer at torres
district council
democratic services officer who's our
clark
meeting that's that i think is everybody
okay right the first item on the agenda
is apologist for absence but i think
we're all here this morning
oh sorry ruth ruth craig isn't his [ __ ]
sandra have you got apologies
no chair no apologies okay thank you
item two on the agenda uh on minutes of
the two meetings that we held them on
the third of september
and then the special meeting on the 17th
of september
which was to reconsider an application
from the third of september
that we hadn't determined so if somebody
would like to move both sets of those
minutes please
and second one i'll move thank you
council
and second chair who seconded them
counselor wiseman
yes thank you yeah that's fine right so
they've been proposed by councillor
watson
secondly by councillor wiseman ander
would you please
go through in alphabetical order the
members for their votes please
thank you chair councillor bangtan at
four
councillor brown
council christy oh
watson
that's unanimous chair thank you sandra
right item three on the agenda
is declarations of interest members with
interest to declare should refer to the
agenda item
and describe the nature of their
interest when the item is being
considered
elected members of devon county council
and town and parish councils
who've considered a planning application
by virtue of their membership of that
council
hold a personal interest and are deemed
to have considered the application
separately
and the express views of that council do
not bind the members concerned
who consider the application afresh
item four on the agenda is agreements uh
between parts one and two
well there isn't any part two on the
agenda
uh item five is urgent matters of
information
and i've nothing urgent to bring up and
i don't think
nobody else is showing that there's
anything they want particularly brought
up at this
moment so i'll move on then to
item six which is public participation
and this is where i advise the committee
of any prior request to speak
made by members of the public and advise
the details of the council's
public participation scheme well
we have got for the uh water mede
heartland application
uh john dennis speaking against
chris shand speaking against sam duo
in support he's the agent mike beaton
in support who's the applicant
councillor dart
one of the ward members and councillor
harding also a ward member
they're the speakers listed for this
morning
and after the officer has given the
presentation the application
there's no town or parish council
representative from heartland to speak
so it will be first of all the two
public speakers who wish to speak
against the application
and they'll get three minutes each and
then the two
public speakers in support of the
application they'll get three minutes
each
and then the board members the two ward
members council adult
council harding they will then speak
last and there's no restriction in time
but we do ask that they're a reasonably
brief with it
so they're that they're who are listed
to speak this morning
planning applications item seven though
the information and recommendations and
advice contained
in the reports are correct at the date
of preparation
which is more than 10 days in advance of
the committee meeting
due to these time constraints any
changes
or necessary updates to the reports will
be provided
in writing or orally at the committee
meeting
and then we move on now to
the application the first application
application 7a
one oblique 0496 2020
full application on pages 9 19
to 35 which is the heartland one and
i'll hand over to
uh james jackson our planning officer
will give us a presentation
thanks james
thank you chair um yeah before we start
can i just ask councillor christie let's
put his hand up to speak
yeah can i just ask on the screen in
front of me it says the erection of
three
tree houses in my agenda
it says to you on the screen no
sorry sorry yes i'm with you
direction of chewie
they've reached submission for the three
that were previously
which was withdrawn okay
all right james okay thank you chair um
yes as
as as you've said on the uh the case
officer for this item item 7a
um one oblique zero four nine six i
believe 2020 oblique full
uh for the reaction of two tree houses
resubmission of a previous application
for
three tree houses uh this is the
site location plan um the site is
outlined in
red comprises the uh two locations for
the
the proposed units of tourist
accommodation
um also includes the parking area
and a existing stable building to be
demolished
and also the access track that goes back
to the public highway
there's also a very small red edge over
on the eastern side of the site which
you may struggle to see there but that's
that's just indicates a concrete bunker
which is also to be
demolished as part of the proposals
this is the existing site plan just to
give it a bit of context um
you can see on the left hand side there
we've got the existing dwelling
in brown and then the existing holiday
lat
which is also operated by the applicants
and we've got the
existing barn there um and
the stable building to be demolished
this is a proposed site plan it is quite
um i've just put this in for context
really just so that you can see the
context of the site within the
surroundings it is within
um a valley here uh we've got the abbey
river that flows just to the south of
the site all of this sort of white area
going through the middle is the valley
floor
and then we've got the uh the slope of
the valley on the northern side sort of
slopes upwards
and towards the north this slide shows
that in more detail release this is a
bit more
clear uh going from left to right we've
got the uh
the access into the site here that comes
around
to the bottom of the cartilage of the
existing dwelling
and the existing holiday let the
existing dwelling house which is
is owned by the applicants is on the
left-hand side there
then to the right of that the existing
holiday left here you can see the
proposed parking area the existing barn
which will remain existing stable block
which would be demolished as part of the
proposals
and then you've got the two treehouse
locations to
the right-hand side of the barn proposed
locations one and two as clarified on
this
slide the vehicle access would would
stop uh to the left hand side of the
existing barn that would be the parking
area
and as proposed then it would only be
pedestrian access
up to the units of accommodation
basically they'd come around to the the
eastern side of the
the existing barn and then there's a
pedestrian track
in behind that hedge row which is the
kind of blue
dashed line which would then provide
access to
both the units of accommodation as
proposed we've got
a package treatment plant which would
which would serve both of units of
accommodation and with discharge to the
river abbey
to the south
here's the north and south elevations
uh the south elevation is what you would
see from
uh viewed from the valley floor uh as
you can see
we've got between floor level
and excuse me finished floor level and
roof level is four meters
uh the the accommodation would be higher
than that because it is
um supported on a structure of stilts
which would then be mounted on pads
within
within the ground level um
in terms of the materials the
the external walls and roof would be
formed from
timber shingles the windows and doors
would be in hardwood
the decking stairs and handrails and
sporting structure all constructed from
large timber
in terms of construction the both units
would be constructed in a sort of
modular arrangement off-site and then
brought onto site
and then installed in the proposed
location shown previously on the site
plan
here's the east and west elevations
proposed floor plan here um you can see
it's
effectively a central kind of core area
which forms the
living dining room and kitchen area and
then we've got a double bedroom offline
a bathroom off that
also a single um bedroom off that as
well
there's also to the sort of south side
of that drawing we've got
the external decking area and also the
steps that would provide access to the
to the units
this uh just i've included this slide
just so you can see the gradients on the
on the on the valley uh valley slope
here
um you can see the steepness of the the
gradients here
um both of the units of accommodation
would be no higher than
96 meters aod just to provide a bit of
context over to the
uh the eastern side of these units
there's an existing quarry and that's
the top of the quarry is approximately
103 aod
this is the landscape character types
for uh for the
heartland peninsula the one we're
concerned with today
is that blue linear line throughout the
center that is
landscape character area 3h
uh that's the secluded valleys
that's approximately five kilometers
long and you can see the other lct's
there
within the heartland peninsula
this the application is accompanied by
an lvia
these are the uh viewpoints from that
lbia
the three viewpoints that have been used
are the three on the
on the eastern side vp01 to vp03
this is vpo1 looking back to the site
these are from public views the shows
that the treehouses would not be visible
within the lower valley region and
indeed nor is
water mead the dwelling
bpo2 you can just see
on the right hand side the top level of
the
disused quarry
and vpo3 then
this is the environment agency flood
zone map the dark blue
area is flood zone 3 and that is
effectively
the valley floor obviously with the
river abbey there
the locations for the units for
accommodation themselves are actually
within flood zone one
um and the path that you access those
two
units actually carries on and goes up to
higher ground so in the event of a
in a flood event there would be an
evacuation
um means of escape for any guests
staying within
the accommodation
just some photographs here to give you
some context the top two
are the visibility um from the
access as you can see visibility is good
there in both ways
bottom left we have an adjacent
residential dwelling which is located
within
close proximity to
to the site the center bottom
one is the public right-of-way which is
over to the west of the site
and the portrait photo
on the right-hand side that's just a
picture of
the lane approaching the site there
small photographs top left is the
existing dwelling owned by the applicant
uh center top is the existing holiday
left also owned by the applicant
and these four internal photos of the
existing holiday that
from from inside
top left photograph is the proposed
parking area that's just to
the western side of the existing barn
center top
is again the barn which would remain and
that timber stable building which would
be demolished as part of the proposals
top right is the river abbey which would
flow through the southern part of the
site and would be used for the discharge
from the package treatment plant
bottom left is the existing pond which
is in fairly poor condition at the
moment
that is proposed to be improved through
the ecological management plan bottom
center is the first location for one of
the units of accommodation it's just in
between that gap there between those two
trees
and bottom right is the proposed
location for the
other unit of accommodation which would
necessitate the removal of
eight um individual specimens
um what we have in this this area is um
uh signs of uh ash dieback which is
quite prevalent unfortunately
the the eight trees to be removed are
all infected
and there's also signs of infection of
other trees within
that specific area and also within the
valley
this is just two this is looking back
from the uh the
valley floor uh the two proposed
locations are there indicated by the
blue arrows um the photograph on the
left on the left hand side you can just
see the existing timber
building to be demolished um
from the barn i believe it's
approximately 12 meters to
that location for the proposed treehouse
the other location is approximately 50
meters
from the existing barn shown on the
right
and just some final photographs the top
left is from
taken from the pond looking back down
the valley to the west
in the distance there you can see the
timber stable building to be demolished
and the existing barn to be retained
on the top right is a photograph looking
back across the valley floor
bottom left is the concrete building
that i referred to earlier that would be
demolished as part of the proposals
that's
proposed as part of the application and
bottom right is the existing quarry as
well
um there's that was also included with
the proposals um
in terms of the revegetation of that of
the quarry
material considerations relating to this
application are the principle of
development
uh character in appearance residential
humanity biodiversity local economy
highways flood risk and surface water
drainage power water drainage
and other matters the reason set out in
your offices
report is recommended that permission be
granted thank you jeff
thank you james thank you for that
presentation but well we've got
um the speakers that i listed at the
start i don't know
if they're all here or not but the first
speaker i've got listed
is to speak against it john dennis
dennis is john dennis here
nope i can't see him on here is the
second speaker against it chris shannon
is he here
nope and they've not put any they've not
sent in
any written representation to be read
out at all
uh no chair i haven't received any
written representations and they've not
contacted us anywhere to say why they're
not here then
they've obviously been sent the um the
connection to it
to the meeting right
okay well they're not here to speak so
i'll move on is sandura here
who is the agent for the application the
applicant
sure i'm here right well
um mr you've got three minutes to speak
in favor of the application if you'd
like to start now
okay thank you i'll just start my
stopwatch sorry
uh yeah good afternoon members hope
everyone as well
uh my name is sam duo and i act as the
agent for this application
i'd first like to thank members for
their time today and the case officer
for the well-structured and easy to
understand report
as the officer explains this application
is resubmission of a previously
withdrawn scheme the previous
application was withdrawn
primarily due to the new immersion local
plan and the concerns raised by the aumb
and devon county highways the
continental development has been reduced
down to just two holiday net tree houses
and a considerable amount of expense has
been incurred in producing a new design
layout and a detailed landscape and
visual impact assessment
a pre-app or pre-application was then
submitted with this assessment
prior to a formal resubmission council
officer comments
were received and taken into
consideration in further design
iterations before submitting the
application that is before you today
there's no objections from any
consultees other than the aomb
who still express some concern which is
very disappointing as they have
seemingly not taken into consideration
a number of important benefits to the
scheme such as
the fact that the tree houses would not
be visible from any publicly accessible
points of view
the significant direct and indirect
benefits to the rural economy
the comprehensive ash replanting program
to mitigate the effects of ash dieback
the replanting and regrading of the
quarry
the removal of two redundant buildings
and the extensive ecology management
plan
which will provide a significant benefit
to the appearance
but also the function of the aomb
indeed this is echoed in the case
officer report
the north devon tourism strategy states
that tourism is one of northern
devon's most important sectors estimated
to be worth over a billion
uh half of it in surrey and to support
more than 11 000 local jobs
this is particularly important to some
of our most rural communities such as
heartland
where it's often difficult to find
businesses and employment that are not
in some way relate
reliant on tourism the application has
received a significant number of letters
of support
which emphasize the legitimacy behind
the proposed development
and show community support for the
benefits that it will create
proposed development meets all local and
national planning policy
and this is echoed by the positive
recommendation by the case officer
the case officer considers that the
proposal would not only have
would not have an adverse impact on
highway safety residential immunity
the existing public right-of-way or
flood risk and would be served by an
appropriate means of drainage
and emphasizing extremely localized
impacts on the aomd
and we hope that the committee will vote
in favor of this application
and thank you all for your time today
thank you chad
thank you thank you mr dior uh the the
second speaker in favor
is the applicant mike beaton i don't
know if mr beaton is here or not is he
here
thank you thank you mr beaton you've got
three minutes as well
to present your case if you would thank
you
no problem good morning chair and
members of the plans committee i'd like
to thank you all for your time
and consideration of our proposal um our
dream is that this application for
sustainable small-scale
high-quality nature tourism will help
fund the sensitive management of our
entire 20-acre site at water mead
we're already working with the bumblebee
conservation trust the north devon
biosphere reserve and the west country
rivers trust
on a few projects on site and the income
from these tree houses will enable us to
take this work a lot further
like many others and our family been hit
quite hard by covid
both with our jobs and with lockdown
preventing us letting out our existing
holiday let
this proposal will provide additional
and more stable income
nature tourism is an amazing opportunity
for our area to recover
now that we face a recession due to
covid this proposal for two reversible
and low
impact tree houses will help attract
visible visitors and support the
recovery of the rural areas
and we know this both from the research
and from our existing holiday lab which
is fully booked
perhaps the saddest discovery we've made
at water meat was that of ash dieback
the disease is a threat of national
importance and it has already killed
hundreds of trees at water meat
without both a plan and the finance to
enact it much of our establishing
woodland would revert to scrub or
pasture
this is a very real threat to landscape
character and is referenced in the
planning offices report
this is why we've submitted our
landscape ecology and woodland
management plans with our application
as well as replanting a minimum of 2 000
trees under a forestry commission plan
we will plant 55 metres of new wildlife
hedgerow restore 150 metres of degraded
hedgerow
create a wildlife pond wildfire meadows
erect 16 bird and bat boxes and four
high binoculars across the site
we've received a flood of local support
with over 80 letters from residents
including the majority of local
businesses
the letters make it clear that heartland
and torridge rely on the income from
tourism
without the visitor economy heartland
would not be able to support the shops
hubs and facilities that are important
for the whole community
we will be providing new dedicated
holiday lake units rather than taking
homes out of the local
housing market and we will improve the
quality of
accommodation with a bespoke and quirky
product
the parish council voted to support the
application as has the chair of the
southwest tourism alliance
and the owners of local attractions such
as the big sheep in the milky way
we were also invited and have submitted
a full application
of defra rural development growth
programme funding
the scheme aims to create jobs and
extend the tourism season
and provide wider benefits in the rural
economy
torridge's economic development officer
chris fuller has written in support of
our application
noting that eco treehouse accommodation
fits firmly within the ambition of
growing the nature tourism offer in
torridge
if we are going to secure the best
future for heartland and for torridge we
need new and innovative ways to attract
visitors that are interested in our
world-class
culture heritage wildlife and landscape
as one of the first north devon
biosphere business partners
we are committing ourselves to
sustainably connecting visitors with
nature
we will help educate and provide access
to the aonb
could you wind up now please sir mr
beaton we hope the committee will vote
in line with your officer's
recommendation to grant the application
and we're very happy to answer
any questions you may have thank you
thank you chair thank you mr beaton
now before i move on to sean i think
you want to speak because i noticed that
uh
mr shandy's now here yes thank you chair
um i'm just looking at the public
participants and we do have
a member of the public who's obviously
having difficulty unmuting themselves
um so it's obviously to your discretion
chair
um i think democratic services will be
able to unmute them
uh if you so wish is this one of the
public speakers
um we're not sure because the name is
just mrs second fire so
we're not sure who that person is until
we mute that person
well i've got i've got the name chris on
the screen here
yes yes that's correct
is that chris shand yes
well i'm disappointed that you weren't
here at the start because
we were here but we weren't let into the
meeting
all right well the normal
the normal process is for those
objecting to an application to speak
before those in favor of an application
but as soon as you've had a problem uh
getting
into the meeting mr shand i'll give you
your three minute period
and it would start now thank you thank
you mr chairman thank you this is john
dennis
mr chairman each of these
just one moment please speaking to chris
shannon well we're sharing we have
advised you
the council that we're both speaking
from the same computer
well i don't know that i've just gotten
two separate speakers listed
so is is just one of you speaking
against the application
no both of us all right so john
john dennis you are speaking first then
yeah thank you mister
you've got three minutes from now then
thank you thank you mr chairman
each of these proposed houses with
terraces would have a
100 square meter footprint added
together these footprints are greater
than that of water means existing
residential dwelling
and holiday unit combined the proposal
is not replacing any
existing floor areas if built the
footprint of the existing the tallest
accommodation would
would be increased by more than 300
percent
the scale of this development does not
therefore comply with policy dm18
2d yet the committee report attempts to
justify it with reference to the
aesthetic design
and a height measured merely from the
top of the stilts to the roof line
the report does not address the large
footprints actual
overhaul overall heights or the fact
that tourist numbers will be trebled
all the environmental enhancements
proposed in the application
can and should be achieved without
development in the same way
as land and ash dieback is managed
elsewhere in our district
due to the outdoor nature of the
accommodation together with its tranquil
location
residential amenity would not be
protected by the visitor management plan
paragraph 13 3 of the local plan and dm
14d have not been considered and
neighboring dwellings would be adversely
affected
the proposed buildings are no more eco
than any other new build houses
conforming to part l
of the building regulations and as they
are built in clearings
neither should they be described as tree
houses
associated extensive infrastructure
works will have a serious impact on the
ecology of the valley
the economic benefit is exaggerated the
application form states the creation of
1.5 jobs while the committee
report says three any economic benefit
would be insignificant compared to that
generated by the additional 104
new dwellings scheduled in the heartland
spatial strategy
approval of this application by
directors of a registered development
company
would set a precedent and open up a real
possibility
for further similar development along
this special valley
finally within the north devon and
torres districts the biosphere reserve
extends to 3 300 square kilometers
with this reserve the the aomb
covers an area of just 171 square
kilometers
this sensitive area is identified for
special protection
together with the district councils the
aomb's
environmental experts serve to protect
the district's most precious
asset both the aonb and cpre
have recommended refusal of this
planning application
it is wrong that the committee report
disregards that advice
and we urge you to refuse this
application
thank you mr chairman thank you mr
dennis and now
the second speaker against in is mr sham
and you have three minutes also mr
schumer
thank you mr chairman this planning
application is for new tourist
accommodation
in the undeveloped coast st 093
is the only section of sto9 which refers
to new tourist accommodation
and only supports it in the developed
coast
paragraph 4 53 says tourism
accommodation which does not utilize
existing buildings should be located
outside
the undeveloped coast st 14h
says plans and policies which aim to
protect
and enhance the undeveloped coast must
be supported
these provisions are not mentioned in
the committee report
st 11 7 says proposals for development
of the rural economy
must not conflict with other local plan
policies
when dealing with design and impact the
committee report
focuses on the summary of qualities
general
to all lct 3h valleys
it notes the high levels of peace and
tranquility
mentioned by the aonb then justifies his
proposal by reference
to documents submitted and paid for
by the applicants why are the torres
district council landscape
and planning guidelines for lct 3h
valleys
not mentioned the first guideline
says linear spread of development along
river valleys
should be prevented to maintain the
settlement's characteristic form
and peaceful character the second
guideline
says new development should utilize the
landscape's
traditional building styles and
materials
particularly exposed local stone and
slate
the proposed buildings do not fit this
requirement
this also conflicts with the heart and
design guide
and dm182f
further parts of the heartland design
guide are not met
as the buildings would be in a remote
location be higher than
existing buildings to not enhance
existing building
groups and are not low cost temporary
structures the narrow partially stone
wall stone walled road to the site
is signposted as not suitable for motor
vehicles
the original dcc highways report
said the road could not support this
development safely
for all road users this is also the view
of the aonb
when considering 18 2e
yet this location is heavily reliant on
the car
this application should be refused it is
in the aonb
in a unique lct 3h valley in the
undeveloped coast
it is outside the heart and development
boundary in the open countryside
could you wind up would you wind up now
please mr sham yeah
it does not comply with the local plan
policies
landscape and planning guidelines and
ignores the stronger
objections of cpre and aonb
thank you mr chairman thank you mr
schaum thank you
right the next speakers for this
application
is the two board members listed and
first it's councillor dart
and councillor dart you've there's no
time limit on your
uh contribution thank you chair i'll
keep it brief anyway
i don't intend to say too much on this
application my calling basically says it
all
um other than it's proved to be one of
the most contentious
within heartland parishes within my
10 years of being a district councillor
which is quite disappointing really
um i therefore felt it was only right
that this was given a full public debate
within the wider scope of torridge
um it wasn't a decision i undertook
lightly because there were implications
um however um ultimately
it was necessary um i don't doubt that
this is an absolutely
fabulous idea um and it will
benefit the rural economy and how much
is questionable but i have
no doubt it will be a benefit the real
crux
of this call-in is is
this the appropriate place for this
development
in this situation within the aomb
outside of the development boundary and
with poor access roads
um it does it fit within policy or not
the aomb would argue that it doesn't
the objectives would argue it doesn't
the applicants and the officers would
argue that it does
um so i feel that i will leave it to you
to debate and decide thank you
thank you thank you councillor dart and
our final speaker is the
another ward member from heartland
councillor harding
uh good morning chair uh good morning um
plans committee um yeah i fully support
this um
i'm not uh um
bogged down with lots of uh um
uh kind of uh rules and regulations and
that i see it as what i saw
and i went down met the people and had a
look around
and i just felt that it just fitted very
well
to the area um it is uh
been one of the most controversial uh um
uh things for heartland so so um anna
said but
i mean i have never had so many people
um get in touch with me through social
media
supporting as well as um um seeing all
the uh
letters um that was sent in so i mean it
is uh
it is really well supported um by young
and old
but uh but you know it is like more
might some like it some don't
um anyway i'm i
just fully uh support uh the plan um
with uh in line with the planning
officer
as you know tourism is so important to
our area
uh the parish council uh voted to
support it
and um and as they said along with the
economic development officer and um said
west tourist
lions also and
i just think that ecotourism for that
area
is is uh really um important
um the existing let as i said had
only three weeks available left and they
got 20 weeks booked already for next
year so i mean they
there is a business there um the
treehouses will
offer a really high quality
accommodation all year round
and uh for 300 pound a night i think you
know that's
that's a really good for the area uh
obviously the local
staff they'll be helping out and the
shops and everything has got nothing but
to gain from it
um so you know i think you know
the whole thing about this uh is down to
you guys and
and um what you think but i think you
would like to
they have answered everything that had
to be answered um
they've um got theirself in with a
biosphere
business partner now which is quite
incredible really and
uh and what their plans to do with the
area is fantastic
um i think it was a perfect example of a
low impact sustainable timber tree house
um i know it's not stone it's slate but
it sits
in that woodland really really nice um
i just feel that you know i would like
you to
consider this and uh and support it i
think it'd be good for the area
thank you councillor harding well that
uh concludes the contributions from the
public speakers and the two war members
so i'll now open it up to debate of
course the main issue is the fact that
it
is in the o a o m b i've looked very
closely at all these policies
that uh to do with the site i printed
many
off here to refer to later it is on
i think it's right on the boundary the
inland boundary of the heritage coast
but the first um i think james jackson's
put his
hand up to speak if i'll bring you in
james and then cancel a lot to speak
after that
yes thank you chair um if possible i
just wanted to come back very briefly on
a couple of the points raised by
by the two objectives there really won't
label the points too much really but
um in terms of the uh note the first
objectives
stated that the positives of the set up
within the application can and should be
achieved without
the need for the development um just on
that point i do recognize that obviously
that's possible they could bring forward
these
um these positive benefits without the
form of application but as i understand
it then
they're going to need um the development
to cross-subsidize that
and and notwithstanding that in any case
i think the fact that they
that they do form part of the proposal
they they do weigh in favor the proposal
and then we do need to take that into
account really
um in terms of just on the economic
benefit
it's not just about the creation of jobs
but also obviously about tourist spend
within the area and that benefit that
flows through the local economy as well
um and just also on precedent
um as we've sort of raised a number of
times before it is each application on
its own merits
if in terms of future applications if
this were to be permitted
um then we've obviously got the ability
to consider those on its merits if we
did feel that was harmful or indeed
committee felt that was harmful
um then those could be resisted in the
future really
just in terms of the second speaker i
know the comments about sto9
um and policy generally i think the
officer's report obviously sets out the
arguments in that regard but
i would just add really that it is about
harm as well and
and really in your office's view that
there isn't harm because of the way the
proposal has been designed and the
reasons for that i've set out in the
offices report really so
um just about that mind i think um and
just on the design guide
issue as well um in the design
access statement the the architect does
make clear that
that these are really based on the form
of years really
in terms of circular structures with
conical roofs
um obviously it's an interpretation of
that modern interpretation of
acceptors councillor hardin said as well
they're they're not constructed of stone
or slate
um but it it has had direct um
a direct nod to the heartland design
guide in terms of their design
thank you jeff thank you james right
counselor lock
yeah thank you very much um i have read
every single item on
the planning board all the objections
all the support comments etc
and i think it is a very well thought
out scheme
i mean many of the objectives have
mentioned night skies
and the effect that these tree houses
would have but these tree houses have
been designed to protect dark skies the
roof canopy above the windows
they've fitted blackout lines and
there's intelligent placement of the
internal lighting
and all internal and external lighting
has been designed in accordance with
dart skies guidance
and the design has been well sought out
there's a lower roof level with natural
curves to blend in with the wooden
location
which is in line with the heart and
design guides
um the applicants have entered into a
long-term woodland management plan
showing a long-term vision to increase
biodiversity and create a rich
and diverse woodland and wildlife
habitat
and the applicants are a north devon
bars their business partner which is a
great commitment to
conservation um i know that the paris
council was split in their decision
six voting in favor
i couldn't understand first when i
looked at the documentation that devon
county highways
only gave standard advice so
my husband and i were out for drive the
other day and on the second attempt we
actually found this property because
it's not marked from the road
and um there's no
problem whatsoever with visibility
although it's not it's
um a track to begin with but it's on a
bend and the visibility both up and down
the hill
is extremely good um the only thing i've
got to say is
um footpath number four i know that the
proud officer says that the footpath is
not actually affected
but it is close to the site and should
permission be granted the right to close
order or build over the prayer um
because it must remain open at all times
i don't know whether it would be
possible
to put a condition if it is grounded
that the
public footpath should remain open at
all times even during construction
so i don't know whether the james can
come back on that if we could condition
that
thank you thank you chair and thank you
cancer lock um
in terms of the um the footpath is
actually over to the
the uh west of the site so i note the
the comments from the um prior officer
but it wouldn't be affected so
i think in terms of the condition it
probably fails to meet um the test of
being necessary but certainly we could
put an
informative on the on any forthcoming
planning permission if that would give
cancer a lot sufficient comfort yeah
well with that information then um if a
good button
forward should it be granted i would
recommend approval as per the officer's
report but i wait to hear what other
counselors say but i do recommend
approval
thank you thank thank you councillor
councillor watson
thank you chair yeah i i must have i
must admit i've gone through this
two or three times now and i do agree
with what counselor lock is saying
and i can't really add a great deal to
that but
if you go past this uh pasta turn into
water mead
and you follow the road up there there
is a place there is a site called
coastal camping uh cabin and glamping uh
which is just i probably only a mile
further up the road
this this site is only half a mile from
heartland
and if you drive out of auckland to
where you turn off for this site
there are numerous of properties on that
road
numerous i i'm impressed
for once um how many people are
supporting this in 10 years while i've
been on plans committee
i don't think i've seen as many people
in support for an application
the far water is okay
paris council of four environment
officer
i've got no objections highways standing
advice
and there is a good lighting system
which rose as well cancel a lot sorry as
said
the woodland plan is fantastic i
understand about
dieback i've got 10 just at the back of
me
that have to come down with ash dieback
if you don't have them taken down they
rot and
one and sometime or other if you walk in
there
you will get hit by one of the branches
that
actually drop off and you know
for me i i understand that and i can
prove it
um so if the council lockers
gone to uh uh
think you've gone for approval
counsellor
yes i have yeah
any other counselor want to contribute
to the debate
counselor brown
yes thank you very much i am what this
the first two counsellors have really
sort of gone into the detail which is um
i do approval i just wanted to add
things that have been said before
heartland council are for this
there is an existing track along from
the highway for
access to these tree houses the height
is just over four meters and they're on
stilts
i think the construction and design is
great and
and and it's something new for the area
i'm very innovative really
i do know that they will be constructed
off-site
and they are mostly in wood so
sympathetic to the surroundings
environmentally satisfied with the
discharge to the river abbey
so i don't think these are going to be
intrusive and therefore i would go along
with the approval chair thank you
thank you councillor brown councillor
christie
thank you um yes i don't have a much of
a problem with this
um i'm very aware that in planning
there is no precedent so this isn't the
precedent for other developments
um i've spent the last two weeks
chopping down
ash trees that have been affected and i
was quite impressed with the idea that
this is going to be replanting in this
area as part of part of the scheme
and there's just one thing that does
slightly worry me
can we put a condition on that these
tree houses cannot be
sold separately because
looking at the spec for them looking at
the plans these are actually
really uh quite attractive
things to live in uh you may say well
they're very small on that but
some of the bed sits in my water even
smaller than this
can we actually put a condition on
saying they cannot be sold
separately because i don't want to end
up with a situation we had
many years ago at lenwood where holiday
chalets were sold off
and it was really very difficult to try
and control
the zone there can we actually do that
uh well i think damien hunter could
probably answer that
or or sean might i would have thought
they could be tied to the
holiday letting business that's what i
would have thought it could be
james could you answer that
yes thank you chair and thank you
councillor christie um in
your office's view again a condition
probably wouldn't meet
the necessary tests although if members
did feel that it was um
something that did need to be controlled
um then we could
look at the the potential of a legal
agreement through section 106
that would tie the accommodation to um
to the existing dwelling or the existing
holiday lab something like that
yeah well i i take um notice of what
councilor christie just said because
the lenwood site was a disaster in the
end how that was
and we've also had in the past of course
uh agriculture developments that have
been sold off separately from are not
tied to the land they're not tied to the
actual business
and i would have thought really these
ought to be tied to the business which
is a
holiday letting business um so i think
that
needs to be done james in my opinion
anyway
chairman it's damien hunter speaking the
solicitor
just a quick word just to say i'd agree
with james that it would be best to tie
it by way of a section 106 agreement
right okay thank you yeah yeah and then
that would answer that question of
counselor chris is that they
can't be sold off as independent
dwellings then
anybody else want to contribute to the
council brown you've still got your
tick showing or have you finished
speaking
yes thank you chair okay
anybody else want to contribute right
well i'll
i'll have my two pennyworth and i've i
looked yesterday
as councillor locke has done nearly all
the uh
responses on the planning portal
and i've also looked at all the policies
that apply to this
application and of course it boils down
to the effect
what effect would these two uh
tree houses or houses amongst the trees
equal
dwellings have on the aomb and the
heritage coast
and i think it's obvious that they're
going to have very minimal impact
on that aonb in my view there is bennett
there are benefits from this i mean
we're getting the
demolition of that rickety old wooden
bomb building we're getting the
demolition of the old concrete
shed further down the valley which i
would imagine
is a real eyesore in the valley they are
improving the quarry the old quarry
there's being planted and
they're obviously from what's been said
and what they've submitted
the they've got the ecology management
plan in place for the site
and the impact is very minimal on the
area in my view
and that's the reason that i'm
supporting the application for approval
because it of the minimum impact it is
an important landscape we know that
and these coombs and valleys are
important but it's it's quite a way in
from the actual coast
didn't as if it sat right on the coast
with views out to sea from there
so i i'm going to be supporting it and i
do note
um again there was a the economic impact
of the rural
and coastal self-catering sector in
england i
printed off their report and read it
through yesterday and
there is a huge benefit from this type
of development and modern
modern accommodation like this is needed
if we're going to keep attracting people
to our
area and give them decent accommodation
to stay in whilst they're here
and then of course a spinoff spin-off
from that for the local businesses
um green tourism they're
they're members now of the green tourism
national body
as well as as i think rose mentioned
the north devon buyers for your business
partner they're not
likely these businesses aren't likely
taken on board
by those kind of
companies unless they are exactly what
they've
proposed to be so um i should leave my
contribution at that but i am in favor
of
of this application being approved sean
sean harrington
you've got your hand up to speak uh
thank you chair um
yeah i'd just like to explore this
element about tying the
treehouses to the dwelling or all the
wider business
i agree with mr jackson mr hunter in
terms that it should be dealt with by a
leave agreement
as opposed to condition i'd just like
committee members to explore the actual
planning reason for doing so
normally if we were to do so it would be
due to the viability of a business
to maintain that viability now if one of
these tree houses were to be sowed
to a separate owner obviously all the
conditions to still bite
so it would be tourism accommodation i
was just wondering if we could
have a clear reason for uh
well can i give you one anyway it's st09
coaster nestory strategy
and in its small bracket seven
development within the undeveloped coast
in estuary
will be supported where
where have you gone to i think we may
have lost the chair
uh if we could
well at least we know he's for it
right right i'm starting i don't know
what happened there
i i want to go and put another couple of
bob in the meter i think
right i'll start again to
to to answer sean or answer one of his
points there
i was mentioning uh policy st 09 costing
estrous strategy
little brackets 7 development within the
undeveloped coast in estuary will be
supported
where it does not detract from the
unsport character
appearance and tranquility of the area
nor
the undeveloped character of the
heritage course and is required because
it cannot reasonably be
located outside the undeveloped coastal
history
and that's one of the reasons i'm
supporting because it
it fulfills that absolutely um
chairman it's damian hunter again i take
on board what you're saying with regards
to the policy but i think what mr
harrington's saying is that
members do need to comment and say that
if they
want to amend the motion of approval in
line with officer recommendation to also
add in a requirement for
section 106 agreement i think you need
to give a planning reason for that
i think one of the reasons that mr
harrington was suggesting is that
you could impose it if you believe it's
necessary to maintain the viability of
the business to keep it all together
right thanks for that thank you well
that's exactly what i think why we were
talking about this section one or six
tying the
the two treehouses to the actual
business the holiday letting business
yes chairman it's just that mr havington
was saying that
you need to make it clear why you want
to do that you know because we don't
want
we don't want here we don't want the
risk of these being sold off as individ
independent dwellings
in order to maintain the viability of
the business absolutely yeah yeah it's
just got to be made clear in the
uh reason uh that members are voting
upon
that that's the case so at the moment
we've got a motion that's been put
forward
previously by councillor
by councillor loch and seconded by
councillor watson
uh what we need to do is ask council
lock if she will be prepared to take on
board the
uh recommendation that there be a
section 106 agreement and if she is
prepared to take that on board as part
of her motion
uh the reasons uh that have been put
forward at the moment is
to impose one uh so that it maintains
the viability of the business
and this councillor along uh happy to
include those readings as a part of her
motion yes i am indeed thank you
counselor
and counselor watson you seconded it
didn't you yeah i agree
you're happy with that then i'm happy
yeah okay right fine thank you just for
the purposes of the minutes chair thank
you
okay thank you damian
right sean do you want any more from us
uh thank you chair no uh my point about
viability was just an example that's uh
being used elsewhere i um accept
uh chairs comments regarding st097
um and of course there could be an
argument there that uh the business
being held together
does protect um the area uh and
potentially tranquility of the area in
that it's all under
one ownership for maintenance etc so i
do think that could be a valid reason if
members want to put that in as well but
also
also dm18 tourism accommodation
um at little a there improves the
quality or
increases the diversity of northern
devon's tourism offer
uh it fulfills that from in my view and
also
brackets too there outside the
sub-regional strategic main and local
centers the development of new
and the expansion or rationalization of
existing tourism
accommodation will be supported where it
is related directly to a compatible and
compatible in skill
with an existing tourism visitor or
leisure attraction or
improves facilities for or diversifies
the range of improv
or improves the quality of existing
tourism accommodation
and in all cases the scale and character
of the proposals
is appropriate to the size of the
existing settlement or tourism
attraction and i think it fulfills all
those chairs
chair sean so it's been
i think okay we can
we can go through the votes on this i
think now chairman
it's damian again sorry just to say then
again is councillor look prepared to
take on board all of those issues that
have been raised by yourself and by mr
harrington as part of her recommendation
as long as all those policies um agree
with the
what we are intended to do is to tie it
to the holiday
um trade yes i'm quite happy hopefully i
think it might be helpful perhaps if
sean could just reiterate then exactly
what it is
the reasons that are being put forward
for tying uh
the uh tree houses to the land
uh obviously there's the viability issue
that's being raised and there's also the
policies that have been raised
at least their members are very clear on
what they're voting on
uh yes thank you so we've mentioned the
biography
issues um we're also looking to tie
the holiday accommodation from what i
understand from discussions with members
to the main dwelling in accordance with
policy st09 and dm18
in effect to protect the undeveloped
coast
and particularly the appearance and
tranquility of that area
thank you chair thank you sean right
sandra if you'd like to
go to the vote please
does rose agree yes i agree with all
those comments from
sean right okay right um
this is the recommendation to approve it
then so if you go to
members in alphabetical order please
sandra
and get their vote on approval or not of
this
okay thank you chair councillor bowton
uh four penciller brown
four penciller christy poor
pencil craigie four
penciller leather four pencil lock
or council mcgough
or pencil watson boar
pencil wiseman or
that's unanimous chair lovely thank you
sandra thank you for that right we'll
move on there our next application
is seven little b application one
oblique zero five
zero two twenty twenty it's a full
application and it comes before us
because
the applicant is a staff member at
torridge
and james james jackson i think you're
presenting this one as well
no morning chair no that's me presenting
it
crazy
yeah yeah ready to go okay thank you um
so as as the chair said this application
is before you due to the applicant being
a member of staff at torres district
council
the application seeks detailed planning
permission for the erection of a first
floor extension
the demolition of an existing
conservatory and the erection of a
single-story extension to the rear
and the formation of a lean-to roof to
the existing bay window to the front
elevation
next slide please
the application site is outlined in red
on the location plan before you
the site consists of a detached dwelling
house on a modern housing escape
located within the town of northern next
slide please
i just run through a couple of photos so
this is the front elevation of the
dwelling
shown in the context of the street scene
next slide please
this again is a photograph of the front
elevation slightly zoomed in
so just to guide members the proposal
includes a first floor extension
over the single story garage to provide
an additional bedroom and ensuite
facility to the dwelling
the proposal also includes the formation
of a lean-to roof
to the existing ground floor window
which is just to the ground floor just
above
that navy car next slide
please this is the photo of the rear
elevation
so the proposal to the rear elevation
includes the demolition
of the existing conservatory which you
can see there
and the erection of a single story
extension to the whole length
of the rear elevation to provide
additional living accommodation
next slide so this slide just shows the
rear garden and shows the site benefits
from sufficient immunity space to the
rear for the site to accommodate
the proposed extension and sure there
isn't sufficient
amenity space is retained so next slide
please mr chair can i just
interrupt i can't get the slides
sorry i'm not sure answer craig can you
not see the plans on the screen then
no i know i can't i'm afraid i don't
know why i can't get them
can i remember see us live these members
yeah i can see i can see them yeah
through to me i can see them
uh we just checked the youtube feed and
we confirmed they are on youtube as well
have you gone to setting there council
craigie that maybe you can come out with
him and come back in
quickly yeah i could try
if we just pull this presentation down
yeah you can carry on without me
well we'll wait see if you can come back
on with him all right
chair if we can just wait for two
minutes for concentrating to get back
before we uh
carry on the plantation chair on a point
of order
um when exactly the encounter craig
joined the meeting was she there for the
presentation of the first application
yes she was rude from the start
yes yes she was yeah apologies for being
late but i did see the presentation
sorry chairman it's damien again uh
could i just check
did has it just gone off at the second
uh
presentation counselor craigie yeah yeah
okay that's absolutely fine um
i'm sorry i can't get it but please
carry on
i think have you got the report in front
of you with the
yeah with the detail attached anyway
yeah i just want i just want to be
satisfied that you you know you've got
all of the information
oh dear sorry all right
well you've got the report with all the
detail in there yes i have
counselor craig so we'll continue with
james
uh sorry carry on with the uh tray to
carry on with you
sorry yeah okay so um so this slide just
shows the elevation plan showing the
existing arrangements of the dwelling
house
next slide and the next slide will show
the proposed elevation plan
so again members just to guide you the
proposal includes the first floor
extension being erected onto the current
single storey garage that's to the top
left the proposed length and width for
the first floor extension will match
that of the existing
single-story elements and the proposed
height of the extension will not be any
higher than the existing route
of the property to the front elevation
the proposal also seeks permission for
the formation of a child
pitched lean to roof to the existing bay
window again to the front elevation
and finally to the rear is removing the
existing conservatory and erecting a
single-story extension to provide
additional living accommodation and the
proposed development will be constructed
with materials to match the existing
dwelling
so next slide so the material
considerations are set out in your
report i will just go through these very
very quickly so the principal
development you will see from the report
the proposed extension and alterations
are considered to be
proportionate to the existing dwelling
in line of policy sta6 and dm25 of the
north avenue torridge local plan
character and appearance of the area the
form scale and design of the proposal
fits in with the context of the existing
dwelling
and does not harm the character and
appearance of the surrounding locality
or street scene
residential amenity the proposed
development would not result in any loss
of light
or reduction and privacy to any
neighboring properties
there are no proposed alterations to the
access parking or movements in terms of
highways
and ecology of the application was
supported by a wildlife survey
which concluded the roof was inspected
and there's no evidence of any
protective species
so therefore share the recommendation is
one of approval to you
thank you tracy uh right well i'll open
it for debate now the first speaker
councillor locke
you muted cancel a lock
i didn't have my hand up actually but i
will start um
yeah i see there's no objections from
the neighbors northern town council
recommend approval
and there's no change in the access or
ingress
so i would recommend that the
application is approved
thank you anybody else like to
contribute to the debate councillor
watson
i totally agree with with councillor
locke i've gone through this two or
three times as well
and and basically if if adrian redwood
hadn't been working for the council this
this would never have come to us anyway
so
i i i'll second rose's approval
recommendation thank you councillor
watson
well i think we can see from the
proposers i looked at this on screen
the other weekend there's no effect on
the neighbors from what's proposed
i i've got no objections to it the town
councillors
council lock says are in support if
nobody else wants to contribute to the
debate
it's been recommended for approval by
councillor locke
councillor brown sorry generation i
didn't have my hand up
oh i keep seeing the tick come up
against your name let's see
what's there there yeah
all right it's been recommended for
approval by council lock
secondly by councillor watson sandra if
you'd like to go to the vote
for approval please thank you chair
councillor bowton four chancellor brown
or councillor christie or
cancer craigie or ansel
leather or ancestor lock
or hansel mcgough or
hencella watson or penciller wiseman
oh that's unanimous chair
thank you sandra right we'll move on
with the agenda
agenda item eight is appeal decision
summaries
there are no appeal decisions currently
item nine on the agenda is costs on
appeals
there are no costs on appeals to report
item 10 is delegated decisions
agm b applications page 43
you've got just the one i think on there
which was approved
so we move on then item 11 on the agenda
which is planning decisions
and i'll just read out the number of of
the pages we start on page
44. pages i've done that by hand up can
i ask why the
last one on 44 didn't come to committee
then if it's a major
sorry the last one on page 44.
did that what the cornbread one yeah
well because
it used to be that all large major
applications automatically came to
committee
yeah and for some reason that's not been
the case
at the moment but i think there is a
case actually to bring that back in but
i see sean has his hand up so nobody in
effect
canceled nobody called it in that's the
reason it didn't come to committee
but sean you want you want to have a
word on it uh
yes chair just um absolutely echoing
what you say the constitution doesn't
require that major applications
automatically come to committee
um they need to be called by a ward
member
or member of plans committee or at the
discretion of
myself in relation to this one yes it's
a major application it is a reserve
matters application obviously outlined
had already been
approved and there's no calling thank
you
thank you sean councillor christy
yes i was surprised when i saw this as
council a lot was because
i would have thought this would have
come to us because
uh it is a major application i would
have thought the planning manager would
have brought this to us
um as you say it's not in our
constitution perhaps it's something to
bring up at
the uh discussion of constitutional
changes at our next full council meeting
next week
yeah i i must i must say to you all that
i've had
representations made that major
applications
certainly ones such as they should come
to before the plans committee
um of course it obviously went to
northern town council for their
consideration
um and i think there are
there's at least two district
councillors there on the i think
on the plans committee at northern who
who could have called it him
or any anybody could have called it um
when it's published i mean we all do get
every monday we get the list of
applications
that are published and i think perhaps
we ought to be
looking at but i think when we do
discuss the constitution at full council
it
might be something we'll bring up there
all right i'll move on then
page 45.
age 46
page 47 page 48
and on page 49 the one refused and
not permitted development on there
thank you
right item 12 is exclusion of the public
well there's no part two there's no part
two session
so i'll just say thank you to those who
have watched on youtube and thank you to
all the committee in the offices for
their contributions this morning
and i'll officially close this meeting
thank you